but is his party over him
a hundred plus of boris johnson's
colleagues rebelling against his coveted
controls yesterday the commons no longer
a happy place for this prime minister
rejected by so many of his party and
reliant on his opponents to push
relatively mild restrictions through
mr speaker the parameter is so weak that
without labor votes last night vital
public health measures wouldn't have got
through
but this country can't
this is not true
it's not true
he's so socially distant from the truth
he thinks that that's not true i don't
know where to start we better press on
we can't go on with the prime minister
who's too weak to lead boris johnson in
denial
mr speaker
thank you very much mr speaker
we we won that uh vote last night with
conservative voters i as i told the
house
i i respect i respect the feelings and i
respect the anxieties uh that colleagues
have about of course i do i respect and
understand the anxieties the legitimate
anxieties that colleagues have about uh
restrictions on their liberty but i
believe uh and on the liberty of people
but i believe that the approach that
we're taking is balanced and
proportionate and right for this country
but are things being kept in proportion
and if tougher restrictions are required
the prime minister can't rely on his
party to vote them into law mps are
making up their own minds the government
scientists are saying it's the worst
it's ever been today and the
government's sort of
but government scientists have been
wrong so often before when they've been
saying things that dreadfully bad and
they never were dreadfully bad in
relation to what they were saying you
know number of cases there weren't that
numb number of deaths weren't that
number there so everyone has to make it
that's what unfortunately what we're
politicians have to do we're not experts
we have to listen to everyone and make
them minds up
infection rates are soaring but as we
approach a big new wave boris johnson is
leaving it to you to decide whether or
not to go out see your friends go to
parties
he says it's because of the success of
the vaccination program
but could he even impose new
restrictions if he wanted to given the
scale of opposition in his own party
leaving him pericy dependent on the
opposition
trapped between scientists on the one
hand and his own mps on the other
a year that has aged us all including
the prime minister for him it's been
testing bruising and draining but can he
now regain the authority he once enjoyed
as he faces his biggest challenge to
date sam coates sky news westminster